my only experience with Filipino food is
Jollibee so I have a very very limited
experience I got nothing
did you know what do go on
didn't you go on yeah oh do go on yeah
no I have no idea what this is but I
historically have loved Filipino food so
I'm thrilled oh just like I surprised me
is it something weird it was like more
lift
it's pork I know what pork fat looks
like looks like a tarp it smells
incredible tastes amazing my ass
that's delicious it's really good it's
super flavorful yeah you don't like it
we're reacting how are you reacting with
that is so good I'm like tasting like a
million different flavors this is
definitely something they will serve at
a quinceañera well they should serve a
piece on janna or something it looks
like [ __ ] but that's we don't judge a
book by it's cover I don't know what
this sauce is made of but it's very um
aromatic that's a little mommy if you
will
you didn't answer if this is a surprise
if it is you could say that this was
dick I would be alright so good
it's be a good blood Oh awesome my blood
pork blood you can did you joke that no
I don't give [ __ ] it's good it's just a
meta moral fork in the road as the only
thing I had a bad experience in black
pudding let me guess
you vomited it nope yeah I don't really
know where to go if you didn't vomit it
where did where did you get I tasted
blood then you go or if I knew this was
blood beforehand I probably wanted an
eight it of the blood foods I've had
this is the best one yeah good you want
it you want some good meat and rice and
blood just call me a cannibal man this
pork blood is delicious I'll eat this
all day I don't care this is I turned on
it I want to eat this again Oh
eat other Filipino stuff I want to eat
all the leftovers you have I'm happy you
tricked me because I enjoyed it you know
with that sentence right there can get
you into law or what have you tricked me
because I enjoyed it Jackie that's not
like but stuff happens yeah